[Música]
la iluminación la arquitectura el color
de las piedras aquí todo hace alusión a
Roma y sin embargo nos encontramos lejos
de la ciudad eterna en IMSS
tal como hace 2000 años aquí mismo se
preparan juegos algunos gladiadores van
a luchar
el líder de esta reconstrucción es él
dicta con frecuencia sus clases de
historia en otro anfiteatro el de la
universidad
ningún pulgar hacia abajo eso no existe
llevo 10 años diciéndolo mi papel es el
de director de escena para organizar
todo lo de los grandes juegos romanos y
adaptar la historia a un espectáculo
ante 36.000 espectadores debe ser
inteligible sin traicionar la historia
este gran espectáculo tiene lugar cada
año desde hace 10 años y cuenta con 500
participantes entre ellos jin jinete de
Mérida
esta mañana se muestran las Arenas en
especial a los caballos revisamos
nuestra ubicación con respecto a la
decoración que se moverá Y pues
familiarizarnos con nuestra montura
son actores pero también panaderos
policías o empresarios como Jean Luke
quien participa en sus novenos juegos
romanos
1 2 3 así
la decoraciones están basadas en
esculturas antiguas que descubrimos y en
pinturas y el interior azul así un azul
que se encuentra de hecho en todo el
Mediterráneo
sí Faltan sólo 24 horas para el inicio
del espectáculo
por amor al detalle el líder Eric dirige
sus tropas en latín y en francés cuando
es necesario porque hay un paquete a la
izquierda Qué es eso deben estar
alineados Jean look no están alineados
frente a ti muchachos alineense hay un
hueco ahí hay que taparlo no estamos
bien no podemos ingresar así estarán
listos para mañana
no nunca estamos listos pero Tendremos
que de todas formas quiero decir que es
una repetición normal es decir que nada
funciona entonces
la tortuga la de astérix de los peplums
existió realmente Durante los combates
antiguos es la tortuga más mala que
jamás haya visto
Erick dictará mañana una clase magistral
distinta a las otras compartir sus
conocimientos es el objetivo de este
espectáculo que escribió y puso en
escena
soy de la generación creo que eso tuvo
algo que ver está la idea de transmitir
es muy importante también hay interés
por estas rocas que están aquí desde
hace 2000 años
estas rocas Arenas datan del final del
primer siglo una época en la que nims
era una colonia de Roma hace 2000 años
agente venía a estas Galerías arqueadas
para asistir al espectáculo
había sobre todo en especial aquí gente
de la época romana artesanos burgueses
campesinos que venían a veces de lejos
para poder ver estos espectáculos hay
24.000 puestos en las Arenas de nims es
una certeza que la ciudad romana nunca
alcanzó dicha población Entonces ellos
quiere decir que la gente venía desde
muy lejos para ver estos combates
excepcionales
[Música]
es el Día de gianluca y sus acólitos se
ponen sus vestimentas de legionario todo
debe estar impecable
lo que hay que saber Es que en el
ejército Romano al material le hacía muy
buen mantenimiento
quienes reconstituyen confeccionan ellos
mismos su vestimenta respetando las
técnicas y las materias utilizadas en
aquella época un trabajo minucioso
muchachos estamos listos finalmente bajo
las miradas durante el gran desfile del
ejército Romano
en cada Rincón de la calle la
reconstrucción antigua impresiona
transportaba a la Roma de Julio César el
público quiere más
[Música]
José mil espectadores colman las Arenas
los grandes juegos comienzan
[Música]
nos encontramos muy cerca de la realidad
del espectáculo Romano tal como podía
existir hace 2000 años aquí mismo la más
célebre de la revueltas de esclavos de
la antigüedad en la epopeya de Espartaco
he recogida en el escenario
Jim juega el papel de compañera del
Gladiador revolucionario
en la impresión de que cuando entramos
al toril hay una especie de
transformación yo tengo la impresión de
atravesar el espejo
justas ecuestres gladiadores y batallas
épicas como buen general Erik se entrega
como persona durante cerca de dos horas
de espectáculo para el líder es un gran
éxito
[Aplausos]
inclino por una historia viviente y aquí
demostramos que lo era entre 10.000 y
12.000 espectadores creo que no hay
muchos universitarios que cuenten con
anfiteatros tan colmados
en la pasión por la Roma antigua
está más viva que nunca
[Música]